à ce stade je voudrais également
soulever un problème qui s'est aggravé à
la suite de l'attentat contre mon frère
les enseignants quittent massivement le
navire éducation nationale selon un
rapport de la commission des finances du
Sénat sur le budget 2022 la crise des
démissions continue de s'aggravé mettant
en évidence une périod croissante
d'enseignants qualifiés entre 2020 et
2022 le nombre de démissions est passé
de
3959 à
39270 soit une augmentation de 26 %. en
outre il faut ajouter les quelques 20000
départs à la retraite chaque année qui
ne sont pas remplacés intégralement par
le recrutement sur concours cette année
scolaire
2023224 ce sont plus de 16 % des postes
au concours qui sont restés vacants soit
3100 postes non pourvus
supplémentaires la conséquence immédiate
de ces crises est l'obligation pour le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale de
faire appel à des contractuels non
formés il convient alors de s'interroger
sur les modalités de recrutement
notamment quand on sait que Monsieur
sifrioui le fichier s mis en examen pour
association de malfaiteurs terroristes
criminel dans l'assassinat de mon frère
a été maître auxiliaire en informatique
pouréducation nationale pendant 15 ans à
Paris les conséquences sont que les
enseignants restant se retrouvent avec
des classes surchargées altérant ainsi
la capacité de dispenser un enseignement
de qualité ce qui pénalisera
inévitablement en priorité les élèves
les alternatives proposées pour palier
également à l'absentéisme consiste soit
à demander aux enseignants un
fonctionnement en astintre dans le cadre
du PACT enseignant soit à faire assurer
par les assistants d'éducation
enseignement appelés surveillant un
cours par support numérique fourni par
éducation nationale comme Monsieur Atal
l'a annoncé à sa nomination à son poste
actuel de ministre d'éducation nationale
tout le monde connaît l'expression qui
peut le plus peut le moins en procédure
dégradée c'est qui peut le moins fait ce
qu'il peut ce ni la qualité ni la
pédagogie qui est attendue c'est le fait
de fournir un service minimum en mode
dégradé il y a toujours une certaine
tolérance sur les pertes